[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to "Coffee with a Googler."
In this episode, I'm
going to be chatting
with Justin Quimby who's a
PM on the Tango platform.
If you're not
familiar with Tango,
it's all about
augmented reality.
And this guy gets to work
with the partners that
are building really cool, crazy
augmented reality concepts,
and he's going to come
tell us all about them.
So Justin, you're a Product
Manager here at Google
working on Tango.
Can you tell us all about it,
and tell us about yourself?
JUSTIN QUIMBY: I actually joined
the team about a year ago.
And it's been really
exciting, because I
worked in the video game
[INAUDIBLE] prior to that.
I spent 15 years, actually,
making video games.
I worked on Dungeons and Dragons
online and Lord of the Rings
online at Turbine
back in Boston.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I'm not worthy.
JUSTIN QUIMBY: And
then on top of that,
actually what brought
me out to California
was to work at Electronic Arts
on Spore with Will Wright.
Then I did a whole series of
small start-ups, many of them
buzz worthy wordy and
mobile social HTML 5
free-to-play games.
But for me, after doing
games for both PC and then
mobile titles, I
started looking around.
And I said, well, what's next?
And I started looking at VR.
And I've been a huge fan
of VR ever since the 80s.
And I started thinking
about, well, VR is great.
What about augmented reality.
I had seen little
snippets of what
Johnny Lee had been working
on in the game development
community.
And I said, all right,
I want to go work
at Google with Johnny Lee and
work on the team for Tango.
And so that's led me here
today to be Senior Product
Manager working
on Tango, helping
build the third party
developer ecosystem
for the Tango platform and
Google's larger AR platform.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice.
So what's involved in building
the partner ecosystem?
JUSTIN QUIMBY: It's really fun.
You get to go out and
talk to a lot of people.
But part of it is
about explaining
what is augmented
reality and what is
smartphone augmented reality.
And also, I get to have the
fun job of telling people, hey,
it's not just a
theoretical lab project.
It's actually shipping.
So we've got the
Lenovo Phab 2 Pro,
which is the first Tango-enabled
smartphone, shipping this year.
And it's the first
of many phones
that are going to be coming
out with the technology.
And so it's a really
exciting opportunity
for developers to start
creating apps and games that
take advantage of all the
additional capabilities
that Tango brings
to a smartphone.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And I think it's
interesting from the
developer perspective,
because not everybody
has these phones yet.
But if you start
building now, then you
can get to define the category.
And when I think
about it, you're
right, because when App stores
and Play stores first came out,
there weren't that many apps.
And the first app
that did photo filters
to enhance your photos--
that kind of thing--
that got to define a
category, that got to be huge.
And so for developers
now, it's almost like,
don't blink, or you might
miss the opportunity.
JUSTIN QUIMBY: And the
other thing that's great
is that there is a burgeoning
set of tools with Unity
and Unreal and other 3D
engines to enable developers
to create 3D applications for
Tango-enabled smartphones very,
very easily.
So you don't have to build
your own graphics engine.
You don't have to build
your own particle systems.
You don't have to
build X, Y, and Z.
Think about all the logging
in metric systems, all
the analytics tools
that we have today.
Those didn't really
exist in a mature form
when Android first
came on the scene.
And so developers,
at that point,
were really throwing darts,
trying to figure out what
features people liked,
what they didn't.
Whereas today,
you can study that
on day one with their
well-established beta channel
systems-- all those
mechanisms and tools
to help build great apps.
And it really is
up to developers.
And here's a present.
Here's a present, developers,
of knowing where your device is
as it moves through space
and time and the ability
to put digital objects
in the real world
and pin them to
the physical world.
What could you do with that?
Is that putting a miniature
wrestler on the table
and having him wrestle?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Has
somebody done that?
JUSTIN QUIMBY: Oh, yes.
We, in fact, have
a developer, Adi,
that's making an app Holo,
which is all about taking
augmented reality photos.
It's all about
taking hollow photos.
Think about the holochess
from "Star Wars"
where suddenly there's
a table that has
all these things moving around.
We can start doing that kind
of stuff with Tango today.
The field is wide
open for developers.
What is their idea?
And with Unity Unreal,
it is very quick
to take an idea from a pure
idea to a working prototype.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
You must have worked
with some really cool and
fun and crazy scenarios.
Can you share any of them?
JUSTIN QUIMBY: Oh, yeah.
So I think part
of the fun is when
you can put digital
objects in the real world.
Suddenly that means, well, if
I want to take a photo of you--
you're having a photo here.
That's great.
But what if I can
insert-- suddenly
I've got 15 little wrestlers
from various sizes,
all posing behind you.
Augmented reality means
that not only can you
insert digital objects
into the real world,
but you can also replace
objects from the real world
with digital ones.
So suddenly you could put a
artificial green screen here.
And so you and I, as opposed
to having coffee here,
we might be having coffee
at this table on a beach.
That sounds pretty good.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Can we do that?
Maybe not coffee if
we're on the beach.
JUSTIN QUIMBY: Yes, that's true.
Margaritas on the beach.
We need to get new mugs, though.
When you have
developers thinking
about what kind of
crazy stuff could they
bring from the digital
world into the real world,
you start thinking about,
well, a picture frame
doesn't actually have to have
real world information in it.
Now suddenly this picture frame
could have my rolling Twitter
stream.
One of the great
uses-- and I admit
now, my bias coming from
the games industry--
is that third person,
God-style interaction
games are great with Tango,
because you can place
a digital world on a tabletop
and suddenly interact with it
in an entirely
different fashion,
because you're not
constrained to a flat screen.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
a small flat screen.
JUSTIN QUIMBY: And
a small [INAUDIBLE].
Now this becomes
your magic window
into this digital world
projected into the real one.
And so suddenly now this
could be a cityscape.
I could be putting down hundreds
and hundreds of dominoes.
And I don't know
about you, when I
was playing with dominoes
when I was a kid,
there was always a
very small number.
And we could never have enough.
Now suddenly there's an
unlimited number of dominoes
you could place.
We've got a developer working
with Mattel on a Hot Wheels
game.
And yeah, it's really cool.
So you can actually
lay out digital track
and then put your different
cars-- tweak and tune
your cars-- and have them
racing around the tracks, which
is something as a kid, I always
had my one little Hot Wheels
car.
And I tried to
make tracks for it.
And occasionally my dad--
LAURENCE MORONEY: There
was never enough track.
JUSTIN QUIMBY: It was
never enough track.
My dad would step on the
car and break the axle.
Maybe my dog would knock
over the little ramp
I'd built out of wooden blocks.
Now suddenly you can do all
of that with digital building
blocks.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And then you
look through this little window
into your augmented
world of Hot Wheels.
JUSTIN QUIMBY: Yeah, exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Very cool.
So if I'm to get
started with all this,
what's the best way to
get started for you?
JUSTIN QUIMBY: The
fastest way is to go
to developers.google.com/Tango
and there's--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Easy to remember.
JUSTIN QUIMBY: Yeah,
easy to remember.
And there's all
sorts of information
there, whether you are a
Unity or Unreal developer
and you're familiar
with those platforms,
or even if you're just a
standard Android developer
and you know Java,
we've got Java SDK.
You can get up and running
in less than a day.
We've got tons of
sample applications.
We've got sample code on GitHub.
We've got active
developer forums.
And we're really excited to have
new folks come to the platform
and show us what's
possible, because that's
one of the things that's
fantastic is that someone
working on an idea,
in a day or two
can actually turn that
idea-- that can be
the seed of a massive business.
LAURENCE MORONEY: There's a
whole new set of categories
out there that we
haven't discovered yet.
JUSTIN QUIMBY: And
it's really exciting
because developers each have
a different set of problems
that they personally
experience, their families,
their communities.
We don't know every problem
that will be solved by Tango.
But we believe, and
I strongly believe,
that it is an amazing technology
to help take your smartphone
to be a next
generation smartphone.
And then what are all the
crazy and awesome applications
that developers are
going to come up with,
utilizing this technology stack?
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
if the Tango smartphone
is the next
generation smartphone,
there's a great
opportunity for us
to be next generation
developers.
JUSTIN QUIMBY: Yeah, exactly.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thanks
so much for coming.
JUSTIN QUIMBY: Thanks
so much for having me.
It's been a ton of fun.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Appreciate it.
So if you want to
learn more, take a look
at the description
in this video.
And we've put some
great links in there.
If you've any questions
for me or if you
have any questions for
Justin, just ask them below.
And don't forget to hit
that Subscribe button.
Thank you.